that a lot of people don't understand it
until it happens to them
that's really the struggle because
believe it or not even in this modern
world there's some people out there
where it hasn't happened to them or
they're so good at justifying it
that they don't want to see it right and
so when a person who's going through it
actually turns to maybe a friend who
doesn't get it
they'll often get pushback and people
say oh you know
that's just how they are they're just
intense and
this is not about intense this is about
something so abusive that cuts you to
the core
it's an entirely different experience
and once people understand it
the only thing i've ever wanted for
people is to not blame themselves
because that's what people do in these
relationships they blame themselves and
say
maybe i'm not trying hard enough and
maybe i'm not this enough and maybe i'm
not that enough
so you're doing your part you're being
abused you decide how you want to
proceed
yeah yeah i think that a lot of it comes
down to for me that i can look at and go
i never had boundaries and so like when
you don't have boundaries
and you're a kind loving compassionate
caretaker all of a sudden you become
just like
it's just you can't see through the see
through it
so i'm curious how you got
how you evolved into this place and
speaking about narcissism like you do
did you have an experience
or is this just a progression of your
profession
it's a lot of different things i mean
initially it really started from a very
professional place i'm i'm
also a university professor i was doing
research on it and i was saying
why are some of the people coming into a
clinic we were working with
they are this i said this small group of
patients is taking
everybody's attention and energy and you
know so
this small group of patients was getting
90 of the nurses and the staff's
attention and everyone else was actually
a really nice
compliant client patient they weren't
getting i'm saying gosh these people are
breaking these people down
and that led to a program of research on
this but at the same time i'm also a
psychologist in practice
and more and more people were coming in
and telling me the same story of their
marriages and also were saying
i was in therapy and i worked on
communication and they were really nice
clearly communicating people i said oh
this is what it sounds like
and once they understood narcissism
honestly sometimes in six to eight weeks
they're like
okay got it some would go ahead and get
divorced some would set boundaries
and a lot of them stopped blaming
themselves it wasn't always that quick
sometimes it would take months or years
so there's a whole range and yeah it has
happened to me and it's ironic because
even in my own life i knew it was toxic
i knew it was unhealthy
but i probably about 10 15 years ago i
really started getting into this work
and then
and what i noticed was there's a huge
hole in the world of mental health
nobody wants to talk about it
it kind of feels not nice like it's a
psychologist we're supposed to be warm
and fuzzy with everyone
i said i'm not i have worked with a lot
of narcissistic patients that's what's
interesting probably a third of my
practice
and so and i do great work with them but
i can see
i don't know that i want to be in a
relationship with them but i want to
help them
understand their impact on others and
they themselves are having a tough time
too but
i don't care if you're having a tough
time you don't get to take it out on
other people
so it was like it was a it was a mix of
research clinical interest
and and my personal stuff and it all
came into this and then nobody cared
danica to be honest with you
they didn't care until they cared it was
really probably in the last five years
in this country things switched
the world sort of changed we became more
polarized and when that happened
this word started floating out there
much more at a public level
and then again people started listening
i think i was talking to myself for
about 10 years
before people started listening so it
was all good
so do you think that narcissism is being
revealed
more now or it's on the rise due to a
level of polarization
i don't know if it's literally on the
rise i think a little bit seeing things
like social media
the ability to behave badly on the
internet the kinds of people we sort of
idolize in our society
really are often the noisy bullies and
we idolize people with a lot of money
and narcissistic people always have more
money and so if you say i want to be a
billionaire
in today's day and age and more often
not saying i want to be a narcissist so
it's the people we value we don't value
a teacher who
knocks herself out to help kids who are
having trouble learning that's not our
hero
our hero is the person who has the jets
and the rockets and all this nonsense so
part of it is what we value in our
society but i think what's happening too
is that now that we i think for a long
time
people tolerated this behavior they're
like that's just someone being intense
that's just boys being boys that's just
somebody being difficult
or there's two sides to every story i
mean i've heard every rationale for this
and i've worked with people who stayed
in these marriages for 40 plus years
so they've heard all the rationales for
a long time
and they almost had to go with the
rationale if they were going to stay in
the relationship so i actually think
this pattern has always been around but
i think we found
huge ways of justifying it and now
people are saying enough you can't bully
people at work you can't this is not
okay it's actually taking a real toll
and it's the toll on people that it
takes that's very much a focus on my
work which is
if you bully people and gaslight people
and manipulate people enough you're
actually going to
you're making them sick and that's the
piece i wanted to address
i agree is there before we get on to all
that because
uncovering all the tactics and ways that
could be like someone could be listening
like oh my god that's me
because that's like i like read one that
was like the top ten i was like oh my
god
it's like a solid like one hot nut like
nine out of ten
for sure i was like oh my god i'm pretty
sure this is an a
um but um is there
a healthy i mean because you know we you
say things like if you're successful if
you have the jets or if you make money
and so you know presumably i could fall
into that category to some degree so is
there
is there uh is there a healthy
um level of code of narcissism or
is there an assumed level of narcissism
to everyone and it is truly a scale
so let's not call it narcissism and
let's call it that
because i hate the term healthy
narcissism because i think at the core
of it this pattern of narcissism
the lack of empathy the entitlement the
grandiosity
the contempt for other people the
validation seeking the superficiality
the
you know the lashing out at other people
being arrogant and controlling and
sensitive to criticism and hypocritical
i don't think that's ever healthy right
i do think people can become successful
without those qualities
i think it is a bit more of an exception
than a rule to be honest with you but i
absolutely think it can happen and i've
met
and worked with people who were
extraordinarily successful and deeply
empathic
and they managed to make it work often
because they had a gift like they were
very good at the thing they did and so
because of that they were able to
succeed but i think the people
who had to sort of scrap and manipulate
and work the system
that's a little bit more problematic so
i think that what some of us may have is
healthy assertiveness
um healthy uh competition so the idea
that i'm gonna compete this fair and
square i'm going to
i'm going to put in the best effort i've
got and i'm going to win this race clean
and then i am going to then celebrate
that winning and be
strategic it's the idea of that for a
narcissistic person they may not win the
race clean
and then they will throw under other
people under the bus once they win are
on their way to winning
it's a bit there's a difference yeah
that makes sense so
what causes it i mean this is the very
fascinating and i mean at the end of the
day of all the work that i've done
especially in the last year like i
have realized only more and more how it
really it's all
childhood it comes from the beginning
and so
what what is it what dynamics
uh lead to a narcissistic existence and
you know emotional state or lack of
emotion
well here's where it gets tricky is that
narcissism is one of those destinations
that a person can
that different people can get through
through different pathways
and some of those pathways are more
tragic and some of those pathways are
actually almost more a little bit
not so tragic i guess is the only way i
could put it at the most tragic end of
it danica would be
thinking about somebody who actually
might have had a relatively chaotic
abuse of traumatic childhood
and because of that they may not have
been able to form healthy attachments
during their early years in the absence
of those healthy attachments
they had to grow all these unhealthy
sort of patterns like a defense against
all of that vulnerability
and so they're always punching at the
world they're sort of angry at the world
and in a way if you think of them as a
small
traumatized child we can think of why
they're angry at the world which is why
sometimes
narcissism and post-traumatic stress has
a fair amount of overlap so
there's that group okay then there's a
group of people who have attachment
issues
and it wasn't frankly traumatic in the
family of origin but it might have been
a bit inconsistent the parents might
have been narcissistic themselves or
totally self-focused or all about them
and their appearances and
their lives and their stuff and their
kids were sort of almost an annoyance
and they weren't really available to
them and these are households where
emotion would have been devalued or even
shamed that so there's that
pathway which some people could even
listen to this and say you know
dr romney i'd actually argue that's a
little bit traumatic too and i don't
disagree with that but i'm not talking
about almost like the frank physically
sexually abusive but yes this can be
traumatizing as well
but it's sort of there's a emptiness to
the childhood so you get to go on
great vacations and you know pretty
thanksgivings and all of that but
there's sort of an emptiness to it the
parents are really egocentric
and focused on themselves then we get to
the sort of what i call sort of the
performing pony kind of model of
narcissism
where people are really raised because
they're one-trick ponies they're raised
because
they're great at a sport they're great
at they're really beautiful
they're they're the kid that the parent
gets narcissistic supply from
so the parent almost invests so much in
that kid
these are kids who go into performing
kids are just great at something
but the kid almost gets the message we
love you because
you are so great at this not like i have
this great kid i love and they happen to
have these other interests
the parents almost overly intrude
themselves into the child's life
and the child's identity gets totally
wrapped in this thing they do
rather than who they are and they retain
that performing poniness
all the way into adulthood they focus
only on achievement
and they never learn emotion in fact
these are kids if they're in for example
something competitive
their parent will be like why'd you do
so bad what was that about
and the poor kid just wants their parent
to say that's okay like this is just a
game i love you
that sort of thing can also go into
narcissism and then there's other things
in the family like having a narcissistic
parent
in most cases it doesn't result actually
in a narcissistic child in most cases
having a narcissistic parent
results in having an anxious child but
in a subset of cases that can happen
but we're really talking about issues
around attachment around emotional
regulation
how much the child learns to regulate
their emotions the less of that they're
taught
the more likely they are to become
narcissistic
and then how narcissistically the
parents behaved you know like maybe not
the parents weren't full-on narcissists
but they were super entitled they were
you know really sort of rude and
controlling that can also raise the odds
but like i said
just as often if not more children who
grow up with that kind of parent end up
becoming more anxious
than they are to become narcissistic so
you can see there's a lot of pathways
that can get you there
and as a psychologist i can tell you
when i see the narcissistic people who
came
via the traumatic root they look a
little different
than the ones who came from where that
performing pony
the parents only cared about how things
looked but they didn't care about who
their kids were
they're different they feel different to
me as a psychologist and they probably
but i have to say for a person in a
relationship with with either of these
groups it's going to be difficult
there's no getting away from that you
had touched on this and it's a
it's a it's a question that i have um
codependency because anxious could maybe
presumably be sort of pushed into the
codependent side is that
accurate so let's talk a little bit
about codependency because it's a tricky
term
because here's where it gets interesting
let's talk first about anxiety with
narcissism and then this thing called
codependency
a lot of people think because
narcissists are so
braggy and grandiose and look how great
i am
that they think that they must be
confident and they're actually less
confident than the rest of us
because they're so braggy like you
wouldn't be bragging like if you're
great you're like
thanks so much and just what i do and i
practice and whatever
but the folks who really really have to
put on the big grandiose shows of
look at me i'm wonderful there's a deep
deep insecurity and frankly a deep
anxiety that underlies that
and the anxiety is very much about
they're going to
really some and it's not like it's
conscious like at a deep level there's
the sense of
i'm not perfect somebody's going to see
i'm not perfect
i'm going to get rejected and worse i'm
going to be shamed
and that constant fear of that means
that the minute somebody critiques them
they completely lose their minds they go
completely rageful
they throw a huge tantrum everyone
either is scared of them or
what the heck and then they feel ashamed
of that reaction
and then that makes them mad again and
that's why you're constantly in these
sort of anger cycles
with narcissistic people so that's where
the anxiety piece is on the narcissism
side
a lot of people who end up in
relationships with narcissistic people
have the tendency to call themselves
codependent and i always say to them put
the brakes on
because i'm always a little afraid of
that label because what codependency
implies is also a i want to say a
deficit but like a
a not like a a vulnerability and then
not
getting it like a codependent person is
almost you know completely unaware
clueless call it what you will in my
work in narcissistic abuse
i would i wouldn't disagree that there's
a subset of people who might fall more
into this sort of
codependent i have to prove myself for
love i have to earn love i'm going to
stay with the broken person and rescue
them
i do get my self-esteem out of how well
my partner's doing
i don't disagree there's a subset but i
have to say danica a lot of people i've
worked with
who wrote themselves off as codependents
and then i just basically did some
basic education on narcissistic abuse so
i said are you telling me this person is
not going to change i said honey i'm
telling you this person is not going to
change
and i said that is all i needed to hear
and they really do kind of pop out of it
either they say
i'm just going to cultivate a life
outside of this relationship or i'm
getting out
to me that doesn't feel like
codependency to me that feels like a
lack of knowledge